well hello everybody on youtube this is
philip rosedale and i'm the founder of
linden lab where the company that makes
second life and to answer the the Davos
question hero what well I think we can
do I guess as both people all my answer
for both I know as individuals and
companies and countries of 2008 to make
a role better one of the things that
we've since happen in the second life
that is very moving a powerful and is
something that we try to do and live by
as a company I think in part because
we've seen it happen in the virtual
world the second life is a willingness
to be transparent that is a world in
which we can know more about what's
happening is a better world regardless
of what's happening I think that if we
and I think virtual worlds are a first
example of this if we can be in a place
where it's simply true that it's easier
to see what's going on it's easier to
know what everybody's doing and and you
know what their actions are moment by
moment you know not not what they want
you to know but but in fact what's
actually happening that is something
that I think has the power to make the
world a better place no matter what and
it always works and it's very simple and
it doesn't take governance and it
doesn't take policy so I think that's
something that definitely governments
but also companies and people can and
should think about just being open being
transparent being willing to share what
you're doing with
old which I guess is appropriate given
using you to answer a question like this
and leave a video thank you